john i understand that you were
we're privileged enough to get to play
basketball with president obama now
yeah that was a lot of fun now you got
to tell me uh because everyone would be
curious
what's he like as a as ambassador what's
it like to play basketball with the
leader of the free world well uh
were you on the same side no
i had to play against him
and i wish that the person who was
guarding him would have been a little
bit more aggressive because
he just let the potus go to the hole
every time you can't do that
this basketball if you have to foul the
man to stop him you have to foul him
he understands those are the rules he's
on the court sure and he's really
competitive you know
on one play it looked like he twisted
his ankle and everyone was like oh my
god you know and sat down and he said i
didn't i didn't say we're stopping let's
go
yeah let's go everybody get up we're
playing let's go oh i thought he was
going to pretend he hurt himself while
you guys started to leave he drive into
the basket yeah no no no no he uh would
you have had you been guarding him would
you have thrown him an elbow
occasionally absolutely i would have
pork chopped the president yeah
we have a picture
i believe this is you did you sink this
basket i did make that one i didn't make
that one yeah i'm glad they caught it
because yeah well you can't really see
the ball so we have to take your word
for it thank you
it went in it went in uh
uh i'm speaking of which there was a
pro-am tournament that you were playing
in recently a championship yeah this is
in new zealand new zealand yeah and i
heard about this word is you got a hole
in one i did got a hole in one
yeah he was amazed the family my family
was there there were about 2 000 people
watching it was it was great and uh
this i would think i mean it's such a
rare occurrence and it's a celebrity
event you're a big star they're covering
this i'm guess you have amazing footage
do you want to i brought some if you
want to we'd love to see one let's see
don cheadle's hole-in-one
this is exciting let's take a look
[Laughter]
there it is in the air and it bounced
twice
i was a little sick on that day i don't
know you could yeah you dislocated your
hip yeah yeah
my head
yeah it hurts
thank god i look really bad that was uh
that claymation was made very quickly
uh so i'm taking it there was no footage
of you making a hole-in-one this guy is
hilarious too because it was sort of
with the tourist board so i was over
there with my family and we ziplined and
parasailed and they followed me the
entire weekend
footage of every bad shot i hit me
sculling it off the tv me shanking it
and i think they finally were like we
can't keep watching this and they just
turn the cameras off and boom and make a
hole in there hole in one that's fine
that's well you can keep that claymation
for all of time that's yours yeah
the kids are going to love it let's talk
about house supplies big coup you got
matt damon uh to be on the show and and
he's he's playing matt damon yeah and
tell us how this happened well uh matt
and i you know since the ocean's movies
are you know good friends and everything
and i was at his house and we were
drinking and
got kind of
a little drunk and uh i said you should
just come on the show and just skewer
yourself
and he said that sounds like a great
idea and i got him to sign something so
by the next day he couldn't back out
couldn't back out and he gave you his
house for six dollars
so this is this is uh matt damon playing
uh uh
an unflattering version of that very
unflattering version of himself let's
take a look at this uh clip from house
of lies
you are the most
arrogant
hypocritical [ __ ] artist i've ever
encountered okay and i deal in wholesale
qualities of [ __ ] on a daily basis
your pile
of of of
quivering need and insecurity is only
slightly outpaced by your
insanely overbloated ego it's
unbelievable
okay i'm sorry spaced out for a second
whoa you guys are leaving yeah hold on
hold on
you got that right yeah